okay leute da sind wir wieder herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
mich dass merkel schon ein bisschen
krank an falls ihr euch fragt warum ich
im heutigen video nicht so aufgetreten
wie sonst nicht daran dass ich ein
bisschen angeschlagen bin und nicht so
motiviert bin so mega aufgedreht zu sein
das heißt heute erstmal ein bisschen
getötet das video ja bevor wir loslegen
habe ich eine bitte an euch und zwar
schreibt mal in die kommentare was euch
an diesem video oder meinem kanal in
letzter zeit nervt wirklich nur was euch
nervt ich will niemanden sehen der
schreibt aber mich stört gar nichts wenn
nicht stört ist super ist okay ist alles
fein aber schreibt da nichts in die
kommentare
sondern schreibt ab wenn ihr euch denkt
okay weil es das feld spazieren im video
was würde mir jetzt erzähle ich will mir
dankbar dafür werde das machen konnte
dann kann ich man konnte meinen kanal
weiter verbessern wollen
ihr könnt euch mal ein herablassender
ohne dass irgendjemand und noch mal
wieder nichts ab was mich nervt dann
schon dafür gar keinen kommentar in die
richtung gut leben wir mit dem heutigen
thema und zwar stelle ich euch heutigen
video fünf nervige whatsapp user vor das
sind die fünf typen die mir persönlich
ist auf die schnelle ein gefallen sind
es gibt sehr sehr viele möglichkeiten
für nervige pisa weil sehr viele
menschen nutzen über eine milliarde user
ok stand 2014 600 millionen user
weltweit
deswegen legen wir einfach mal los
ziemlich sein
nummer eins der übermotivierte das ist
so eine sache die ich persönlich nicht
so ganz nachvollziehen kann als ich
meine jeder kann das machen worauf er
bock hat bla bla bla bla irgendwie zum
thema jeder kann machen was er will
aber manchmal frage ich mich so ob mit
den leuten so alles stimmt meine
kontakte durchgeschaut und habe gesehen
dass ungefähr alle von meinen kontakten
in status haben der mindestens so 200
tage alt ist und ich glaube zu einer tag
ist ein guter richtwert also wenn ihr
jemanden habe so einen übermotivierten
der jeden zweiten tag seines staates
oder seiner mutter viel ändert ich will
nicht sagen dass da irgend ein bisschen
komisch
dafür wird ist oder so ich weiß gar
nicht ob so viel von dem typ da draußen
gibt aber so oder so wie gesagt meine
ganze freundesliste er den status
ungefähr alle 200 tage wenn ihr jemanden
habt ihr alle zwei tage sein status
einer profil alle zwei tage dann habt
ihr mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit einen
übermotivierten in orgatec liste
platz nummer 2 und zudem platz für euch
selbst leute die ewig zum antworten
brauchen ja wie erkläre ich das also ich
weiß nicht ich habe einfach auch momente
wo ich so auf einem handy see ok pieper
vor der gala nacht geschrieben weil ich
in dem moment einfach keine lust auf die
nachricht zu antworten das ist gar nicht
böse gemeint das heißt ich denn die
person nicht mag das heißt nicht dass
ich die personen hassel und das heißt
einfach dass ich in dem moment keine
lust hat auf die nachricht zu
beantworten oder mich mit irgendwas zu
befassen was in der nachricht drin steht
dafür bin ich über den ich nachdenken
musste und ich mir ganze denkt okay ich
bin gerade in der uni bilder sowieso
beschäftigt muss gab hausarbeit
schreiben da hat man einfach mal keine
lust auf solche nachrichten zu antworten
aber bei mir ist es echt schon so
mir ist es schon system man muss das
tablet auch absichtlich dann aber nie
meine kumpels oder freunden also wenn er
bei anderen kontakten
das problem ist halt immer nicht sofort
auf die nachrichten antwortet dass die
nachrichten dann gern mal untergehen und
da hat irgendein personen die man
eigentlich mag etwas geschrieben und man
versteckt sondern ich darauf geantwortet
hat und dann geht die leicht runter und
man fühlt sich scheiße deswegen und zwar
wenn ich so was richtig ist oder wenn
damit nicht klarkommt leute seien
erheblich höher was bin ich gerade dort
dann antwortete direkt von werdet nicht
so wie ich zu einem der menschen die nie
antworten
nummer drei nummer drei ist rein
technisch gesehen ein web user aber
irgendwie schon weil die person auch in
whatsapp finden könnt und zwar ist es
die person die keine whatsapp hat das
sind meistens so uromas oder so die
schon lange über die 120 darüber sind
oder mein onkel hat glaube ich auch
keine whatsapp oder habt ihr die leute
natürlich auch ihre kontaktlisten habt
ja auch im rezept rinne und dann hatte
die leute natürlich eine kontaktliste
und wie man heute so schreibt hört ab
und ich sage nicht das wort app gut ist
macht wahrscheinlich irgendwie scheiße
mit unseren daten aber die meisten leute
benutzt airports ab deswegen tun wir mal
so als müsste man whats app benutzt um
mit leuten zu schreiben es ist schon so
tief sentry problem aber wenn so eine
person kambodscha partei eigentlich
schreiben möchte denkt muss
b
keine sms schreiben
alles klar nummer vier nummer vier ist
eine sache die mich persönlich bisschen
mehr beschäftigt mehr sogar ok nummer 2
auch weil ich noch mal zwei leute mich
immer deswegen anpacken euch so
undeutlich deswegen immer anschließen
weiß okay nachdem hier sein können
gedacht und gibt das richtig scheiße und
halte mich dann immer an machen warum
ich so lange braucht auf irgendwelche
wurzen akten zu antworten
bin ich da schon so ein bisschen dreher
involviert aber in nummer vier umso mehr
zwackelmann nummer vier den finger losen
aber den sprachnachrichten schicker
nennen weil diese person einfach
grundsätzlich immer ein
sprachnachrichten antwort egal ob es um
ein thema geht wasser minuten braucht um
star zu stellen wo ich sagen okay es
macht keinen sinn text einzutippen bei
der so lange braucht oder ob zum thema
geht was innerhalb von zwei sekunden
abgehandelt ist immer sprache recht
immer und ich habe schon ein paar leuten
darüber geredet ein paar leute haben da
auch argumente vorgebracht die mehr oder
weniger nachvollziehbar oder sinnvoll
sind zum beispiel luca lehmann max nicht
gesagt dass dies ein bisschen nervig bin
weil luca auch so einer ist oder war
immerhin sprechen gaal hat mittlerweile
nicht mehr
aber früher immer so und ja das gut oder
geile an der sache ist dass man halt mit
dem handy einer bad herum laufen kann
der übernehmen bei machen kann essen
kochen wurde purzeln kann den ball
parieren aber die sache ist es kommt
auch ein bisschen komisch vor man halt
selbst die ganze textnachrichten tipps
und andere quasi die leichtere oder
bequemere version der kommunikation
wählt nämlich eine sprachlich eigentlich
eigentlich ist es relativ unwichtig in
unwesentlich aber das stört schon
irgendwie was man selbst macht sich die
mühe also tippen die mühe allerdings
schon wieder so trendy problem da es ist
keine mühe aber es ist halt was ein
bisschen mehr zeit verbraucht als eine
sprache leicht zu schicken und der
andere verbraucht weniger zeit und
deswegen stellt man sich da an
es zeigt total sinnlos auch wenn noch so
ein typisches campingkocher platte ist
auch so einen sparkasten junkie oder
bist du warst einfach wirklich
fingerlose wissen aber so menschen die
am 1 dies ist ein einfach alle finger
verloren der hände sehe aber so aus und
damit diese weniger privilegierten
menschen auch whatsapp benutzen können
wurde die sprachnachricht 1
für genau geht ganz einfach sie müssen
bedenken wir keine finger also ihr macht
die app auf wander müsst ihr mit der
nase durch die app navigieren auf was
uns gefällt weil ihr könnt nicht
aufheben wird keine finger untersuchte
die person der schreiben burg das ist
hier in dem fall max dann geht es von
jet drauf und dann hier unten müsst ihr
jetzt nicht so leicht den rekord button
treffen heimat ich bin sind gerade auf
nicht richtig funktioniert also optimal
und ja an dieser stelle eine schweige
sekunde für unsere mitbürger die keine
finger haben und deswegen immer nur
sprach nachrichten verschicken müssen
und nummer fünf zu guter letzt kennt
wahrscheinlich auch jeder das sind somit
die benutzer bei den seltsamsten es wird
ihnen zu schreiben nämlich die eltern
entweder die haben irgendwie eine ganz
komische ausdrucksweise und benutzten
überhaupt keine images man sich ausdenkt
jahr 2016
man kann auch mal im kies in der
kommunikation im internet benutzen oder
aber ich weiß nicht wer das kennt die
eltern übertreiben es einfach so klas
mit dem motto ich bin also high war
heute schon beim sport muskel im og
50.000 mal damit eltern abebbte
kommunizieren das immer bisschen seltsam
weil man weiß wie die menschen reden
damit ihnen vorschreibt denkt man sich
so da gibt's dennoch ganz andere
geschichten da gibt es eltern ihre
kinder irgendwie mit bildern zu sperren
20.000 bilder am tag schicken ja leute
das war's von heute in kleines knappes
video wieder gern die ganze geschichte
rein zu kommen ich habe heute meine
hausarbeit abgegeben in der habe ich
letzten drei tage nur durchgerasselt
deswegen kam auf ist ein weniger videos
jetzt zum einstieg etwas kurz und knapp
was sicherlich gefallen und wie gesagt
konstruktive negative kritik heute sehr
gerne in die kommentare und bis zum
nächsten mal